on remet les choses dans leur contexte
quand on est fan de foot comme je le
suis et comme quasiment tout le monde
mais attendez laissez-moi finir quand on
est fan de foot qu'on les droits humains
que l'écologie c'est aussi important
qu'on a des valeurs vous avez parlé de
la religion tout à l'heure vous avez dit
ça rassemble le foot ça rassemble aussi
fraternité c'est de la fête moi j'en
veux beaucoup à la FIFA et c'est dans
cet ordre là qu'il faut dire les choses
beaucoup à la FIFA d'avoir organisé ça
au rabais au Qatar en sachant très bien
qu'ils avaient pas les infrastruire bah
c'est différent
rien à faire alors ils ont organisé ça
au Qatar il y avait pas d'infrastructure
pas de stade ils sont allés construire
cette stades de plus de 40 000 personnes
au milieu du désert des arrêts de métro
pour aller nulle part au milieu du
désert juste pour l'événement ils ont
fait venir des étrangers de partout du
Sri Lanka du Pakistan Ils ont compté les
morts dans chaque pays plus de 6500
morts pour aller faire ce stade moi j'ai
pas envie d'être assis dans un stade
comme ça et de savoir que je suis assis
sur un cimetière j'ai fait le calcul
j'ai fait le calcul du nombre de joueurs
qu'il y aurait dans le nombre d'équipes
x 26 plus de 800 et quelques divisez
6500 par 800 c'est plus de 8 morts par
joueur qui joue au ballon non mais ça
quand on a des valeurs je pense qu'on en
a tous autour de la table c'est
important mais comme vous l'avez dit il
fallait se réveiller avant je suis
désolé mais il se réveille avant merci
beaucoup si les gens évoluent et tant
mieux si c'est maintenant
Amnesty International cette ONG est
magnifique
ne sont pas du tout d'accord avec le
boycott il pense que c'est justement un
sort de théâtre de tarte d'hypocrisie
alors j'entends l'argument c'est de dire
il vaut mieux accompagner ces pays c'est
ça on met la lumière et ça permet
d'améliorer les standards etc ouais
enfin les 6500 morts ils existent et moi
j'ai pas envie de les cautionner et j'en
veux beaucoup à la FIFA genre je vous
propose instance dans quel pays on a le
droit d'aller non mais c'est vrai
la Coupe du monde
chaque chose en son temps là pour
l'instant on a un événement médiatique
qui est la Coupe du Monde
oui non mais non mais il y a eu les JO
en Chine vous avez pas votre côté
alors peut-être que vous écoutez pas
c'est les écologistes c'est dommage
parce que les écologistes la première
heure nos députés je me rappelle en 2011
non 2012 quand ils ont été élus un des
premiers actes qu'ils ont fait on
boycotte la Coupe du monde après on nous
suive qu'on nous suive pas là maintenant
il y a la lumière tant mieux et moi je
vais vous dire la vérité je suis aussi
militant c'est pour ça que je suis élu
je suis militant écologiste militant des
droits humains je profite aussi de
l'événement pour mettre la lumière sur
cette droite Cyril est-ce que
je crois que si toutes les villes de
souffrance plus peut-être de repu
peut-être ailleurs dans le monde font ça
ça arrêtera pas le football et tant
mieux mais peut-être
vont changer
d'accord
moi je vous reproche il crée des emplois
prendre le foot en otage et ça c'est pas
bien vous êtes élu mais c'est oui nous
prenons nos âges vous êtes spécialiste
de l'urbanisme de l'habitat du logement
vrai oui voilà est-ce que quand le Qatar
investit massivement dans l'immobilier
parisien c'est une mauvaise chose oui on
arrête maintenant
tout le temps à chaque conseil de Paris
je vous invite à regarder celui du 11
octobre
de la pleine terre alors qu'on pourrait
faire des jeux on fait du logement
je fais des votes contre
vérifier qui va financer la Chine la
Russie qui va financer
ils ont du pétrole non mais qui va
financer nous pour le financer non mais
qui va va créer des emplois de quoi les
6500 morts là c'est ça
en France par an et demi par exemple
alors qui va qui va présenter
trois prods
il y a personne donc on prend le mauvais
on va essayer de trouver des bonnes
solutions
pour l'hôtel Meurice en l'occurrence
pour l'hôtel Meurice effectivement
insupportable non pardon qui va
insultant qui met les prisons
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de vendre
entièrement Paris et même tout pardon
tu as bien fait de venir on confond tous
les confondent tout toi il sert à rien
en aucun cas il fera avancer les choses
et pourquoi vous laissez pas les gens
tranquilles en quoi regarder un match
sur un écran géant c'est cautionner tout
ce qui peut se passer de mal peut-être
au Qatar ça n'a rien à voir c'est vrai
alors
premier point moi je crois et c'est bien
pour ça qu'on fait cette proposition que
ça peut changer les choses la preuve on
a le débat il y a je sais pas combien de
spectateurs comme ça c'est infuse et
c'est comme ça que les idées écologistes
les droits humains ils font c'est ils
servent des fois c'est peut-être des
coûts de communication c'est peut-être
des choses symboliques mais ça permet de
faire avancer le débat après on verra le
bilan moi je crois que ça va faire ça va
fonctionner alors la plus écolo de la
bande c'est Delphine Vesperia alors déjà
j'aimerais vous féliciter parce que si
on écoute des gens comme vous qui êtes
tournés vers le passé ben en fait on va
droit dans le mur
on peut pas prendre un café sans avoir
une guêpe sur ses couilles derrière
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas contre le foot je suis pas
contre le PSG mais je pense que le sport
c'est censé réunir et là du coup on ne
va pas dénoncer des catastrophes
humaines et climatiques c'est vraiment
une aberration et je pense que notre
survie aujourd'hui par l'environnement
elle est plus importante que la Coupe du
monde et des vies humaines
dis pas qu'on va pas regarder on va pas
regarder la télé aujourd'hui
que le minimum pour des pays civilisés
c'est de ne pas cautionner des
aberrations
c'est quoi les pays civilisés
est-ce que tu sais qu'il y a des gens
qui sont morts pour ça est-ce que tu
sais que dans le désert on va climatiser
c'est une aberration donc on cautionne
pas en lieu public